Thanks everybody for coming out.
Okay, thanks everybody for coming out.
Hope the drive is good.
Yeah, we appreciate you guys coming all the way out, and we're going to come back for
some things here.
So they're, I think, almost ready in the back of the booth, and then we'll get started.
So people on land use screen locations, and we'll have a discussion after that.
We're not ready, so we actually get started.
Thank you.
This one, Lauren, can you guys hear us?
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, it comes in a little muffled when there's multiple people talking.
So if we don't respond to you, we probably didn't hear very clearly.
So I'm super sorry about that.
Are we doing introductions?
Yeah, do you guys want to introduce yourself?
Okay, yes.
Lauren Victor with the Wasatch Front Regional Council.
I'm a long-range planner, and I apologize for not being there in person.
I planned to, but I came down with a cold and figured I didn't want to spread that around
and everyone, so thanks for having us and accommodating us online.
And I'm Liz Scanlon.
I'm with Kimley Horne.
Kimley Horne is a consultant firm that was hired on behalf of the kind of collective partnership
for the Transit Fresh Look project to support and facilitate the planning process.
Dave, do you guys have a presentation for us if you want to walk us around?
Yes, let me make sure I can share PowerPoint.
Thank you.
Can you all see that?
The slides?
In the room?
Okay.
Lauren, do you want to kick us off or do you want me to just jump right in?
I think really quickly, just to kind of mention, yeah, we have a presentation prepared with
some information, and then we also kind of just want to have an open discussion and kind
of hear thoughts, questions, concerns, things like that.
So I think we can start with the presentation, and then we can have a discussion after if that
sounds good.
Okay.
Go ahead, Liz.
All right.
Let me make sure this is all working.
Okay.
And we prepared this presentation and some of you may have been in some of the project
meetings.
So I apologize to anyone who's seen some of this before, but we thought it'd be helpful
just to bring us all kind of together on where we've been, where we're at and where
we're going.
The Transit Fresh Look Study is really about seeking to align a vision for Southwest Salt
Lake County and Northern Utah County and taking literally a fresh look at transit.
We know that transit has been studied and talked about a lot, and there might be a little bit
of fatigue about that, but we are endeavoring to kind of step back and bring new thoughts
to the table.
So this is really about focusing on regional transit connections.
We don't want to forget about other modes like bikes and peds and micromobility, but it's really
kind of how do we connect to Frontrunner in the larger regional system to make sure our
community, our residents can move and get to their jobs and their doctor's appointments and all the
things they need to do.
And we're trying to look at things that maybe we haven't previously explored.
It's intended to be very creative, and really it's about problem-solving to answer the question of
what's it going to take to add and bring new and more transit into this part of the region
in Southwest Salt Lake County and Northern Utah County.
So that's kind of the big picture of what we're trying to do with the study.
Again, Kim Lee Horn was hired to help facilitate this process.
Oh, my mouse is too fast.
Really important that we are clear that this is about a partnership.
Our contract is with the Wasatch Front Regional Council, but it's truly about, you know, our role as a
consultant is to bring all the partners together to creatively figure out what this vision looks like.
So it's a partnership with WFRC, Mountain Land Association of Governments, Utah DOT, UTA, and the eight
cities that are in the Southwest part of Salt Lake County and Northern Utah County.
So Lehigh, Saratoga Springs, Bluffdale, South Jordan, Hermann, Riverton, Eagle Mountain, and West Jordan.
And really, we don't, we won't move forward.
We've really designed a process that allows this partnership to work together and co-create a vision.
And we're really focused on ensuring that that partnership is the one sort of driving this
and ultimately feels like we've arrived at the right conclusion at the end of it.
And I'll talk a little bit more about how we've facilitated that process as we go.
We also have MHTN architects on our team who's been supporting, if there are city staff in the room,
probably pestering some of the city staff at Saratoga Springs, Eagle Mountain, and Lehigh for land use and demographic data.
So we really are trying to understand your communities, our communities really well to help inform our planning work.
Let's go. Okay.
So just a little bit about how we've designed the process.
There's kind of four big buckets that were four big steps that we've been facilitating.
Diagnostic discovery, refining, and blueprint, and really simply boiling it down.
It started with us getting under contract in the spring, late spring, April.
And we started a process on data collection and looking at the existing conditions,
understanding the current transit network or lack thereof, a transit network in this part of the valley.
Really understanding city land use and zoning plans.
And we have spent several months with many of your city staff on doing that.
And really anchoring ourselves to data, right?
So everything is founded on this good foundation that we really understand as best we can.
Communities that we're trying to help plan a vision for.
And then we sort of moved into a discovery of more brainstorming part of the process.
So we're really, we were interested in just like put all the ideas on a piece of paper
and let's stand back and see what we come up with.
And then moving into more of a refining scenario.
So we're starting, we're right now starting to do that.
We're taking big ideas and starting to distill them into some corridors and some focus areas.
And ultimately at the end of this, what we hope to get to is a blueprint for how do we bring more transit into the region?
And what will that take?
What does it really take to do that?
And that could be everything from, do we have the right land use mixes?
Do we have, how do we think about funding and financing?
And what's the path forward, you know, for all of us to work towards?
And again, all this is done in partnership together.
So we've been very carefully working as a group to do all these steps.
Sorry, my slow, my little slow lag on my mouse here.
We've had a couple of meetings.
We kicked off in early April with two kickoff meetings.
We had one in Salt Lake County and one in Utah County.
And that was really about us absorbing and hearing what, what everyone wanted to get out of this study,
really anchoring us all to a common set of objectives and shared vision so that our team understood that.
We met in the summertime, had a really fun interactive meeting where we drew lines on maps and really played around with ideas.
That was our big brainstorming session.
And just in September, which feels like a very long time ago now, we had another meeting where we started to really look at kind of bringing those ideas into some focal points.
And I'll show you some maps of what that looks like.
So we've had a handful of meetings over the last couple of months and I'll talk a little bit more about where we're headed next.
One of the very important things that we started off with early on as we did the kickoff meetings and we started to hear kind of everyone's objectives and what,
what we want to get out of this study was to create very simple goals.
This came from, we did one-on-one conversations with many of our partners.
The project kickoff, we did an online survey just to really dig into kind of what, what is the expectation for what the study helps us with.
And that boiled down to really focusing on better connectivity in this part of the valley, as well as to the region, improving mobility and access for everyone.
We heard a lot about populations that are struggling to move around, get to work, youth, elderly, some migrant and immigrant communities that are all of the, all of the cities we're experiencing sort of demographics that really are looking for more transit connectivity.
Really wanting to look at economic development as an outcome of any of the planning we do that inspires good city building and really aligns with your core values as cities, right?
For whatever your general plan states as being important fundamentally to growing your city.
We want to keep that sort of in mind.
And finally, there was a really, really important emphasis on an implementable plan.
Like not a planning study we throw on a shelf and we don't do anything with, but a plan that all the cities and the regional partners can act at action at the end of this.
So there's clear steps for how do we go from today to growing transit in this part of the county.
So this really kind of anchors our work.
We keep coming back to these to say the ideas that we're coming up with, are they aligning with the project goals or not?
And if they're not, let's revisit those ideas and make sure that we get on track, so to speak.
One of the other areas that we've talked about with the partnership a lot is sort of what we call the five D's of transit oriented development and literally transit oriented development is, is building around transit nodes, around stations or activity centers in which transit
is part of.
And the importance of thinking about these five pillars as ingredients, if you will, to creating good, vibrant transit oriented communities that connect to, connects your cities within each other and connects to the larger region.
So we're going to talk about intensity or intensity or, I guess, density, I know that's maybe sometimes not, but kind of a scary concept.
And we can talk, we'll talk a little bit about the intensity of what we're looking at that's context sensitive to each community's growth plan.
So we're not talking about high rises and anything inappropriate.
We're talking about how do you build a community that really offers a place for people to live and work and play.
And thinking about the distance between my home or my job and transit.
What does that look like?
Talking about the design of how the functional modes will work.
And, you know, I think about a lot if you've traveled, if there's a scary sort of situation because the road is really wide and it's really hard to navigate as a pedestrian.
Sometimes that feels not good and it will detract riders from coming to the system.
So thinking about the design of a friendly environment, a safe environment for, for passengers.
In terms of diversity and destinations.
So diversity is land uses.
It's really getting at that there's a multitude of things happening around a transit node.
Could be that there's a restaurant, there's a dry cleaners, there's residential, there's jobs, might be a doctor's office.
And then ultimately creating destinations that allow us to work out.
So these ingredients all kind of formulate a foundation as we think about the land use and transit connection and how we build, build out our communities to support more transit in this, in the study area.
So talking about a little bit about how we're developing the transit vision.
And this is a pretty big summary of a couple of months worth of work.
So I'm happy to just kind of go through these and camp out and we can talk about it as Lauren indicated.
But started with our diagnostic process, which was us really talking to the community and the partnership and understanding and creating what we called it a universe of corridors.
And this is all these maps are going to be focused on Utah County.
There's a companion for Southwest Salt Lake County.
We got a lot of people together in the room.
We used interactive tools to draw on maps and really understand what's important to you.
Where do you need to connect people?
Where do you see a gap, you know, right now where you need more connection from your maybe town center to Frontrunner or from, you know, where people are living to downtown Salt Lake where they go to work, whatever those options were.
So we had a very, very roll up the sleeves and interact kind of meeting in July in the summertime.
And we really wanted to understand from the partnership where is transit going to be most useful and solve and be part of the solution for connecting our communities in a better way.
And that line work is represented on the map.
This was sort of the outcome of that July session.
So we had like crazy maps with lots of lines on it.
And our team just build it into kind of this is what we heard from you.
And it was really important to us as we took that information from like gathering data and gathering input.
We really wanted to ensure that in September we're, we're, we're understanding it correctly.
We're interpreting what we heard from the partnership the right way.
And so we got together again in September and we started to refine those corridors.
And we really, again, rolled up sleeves and sat down and talked about, is this the right corridor that will connect our communities in the right way?
Again, you're seeing a map of Utah County here and that we really sat with mayors, city staff, various partners, and worked through the lines that really would make sense to connect where you see growth in your community to things like Frontrunner, to I-15, to other parts of the, you know, jobs and other centers north of us.
And one of the things that we also have started to look at is kind of how these perform.
And I'll just say in transit planning, often our metrics are given to us by the federal government.
Often there's federal funding involved in investing in new transit.
And so our framework has been to start with kind of that framing.
What would be competitive in a federal landscape?
Salt Lake City historically has been, the Salt Lake region has been very successful in the past in getting federal money.
So we just wanted to use that as kind of an initial benchmark.
We also want to make sure that we're creating the right connections in the right places where we will have our return on investment in transit is people, right?
The people have access to transit.
It's easy, it's safe, it's reliable.
They feel like they can, they can depend on it to, for all of us to execute our daily lives.
So you can see here on the slide, some of those connections, those performance measures involved, looking at the different connections on these corridors, looking at how would we access Frontrunner?
How would we access other services, other points that are important in our community?
What about the future for land use and economic development?
Are these the right places where we can grow and have more growth in our community around transit?
And then we have started a little bit on kind of cost and feasibility.
We don't want to set you up for failure to the degree that, gosh, we drew a line and it has to go across Utah Lake.
Not really. That's not an option.
But, you know, we're really trying to think through anything that would be a real constraint or challenge in the future that we would want to be really open about and think through with any of the lines that we're drawing.
We're really working at the corridor level at this point. Right. So this is big picture.
Just where are we trying? What what's point A and point B to connect in our communities that's important?
So these lines are a product of that conversation and sort of hot off the press.
You're getting to see something that's very much coming soon to our next partners meeting, which is on November 18th.
And members of your communities are a part of that meeting and will be representing you with us.
This is the latest and greatest map that sort of we heard in September.
We have now drawn more refined corridors that we think really align with connectivity to future land uses and future development to the transportation network,
whether it be I-15 front runner or other transit corridors north to the north and sort of pointing them out and farther into Salt Lake County.
So this is sort of now are we're going to turn our attention in the next meeting to, OK, what's it going to take?
What do we need to do to bring these quarters to life through the planning, you know, through planning?
And that can involve additional land use conversations and creating more access to the new transit lines as we envision them.
And we're going to be exploring bus rapid transit, local bus and light rail as the mode.
So we're going to start talking about the transit mode type or the vehicle that would go on these corridors.
What is the best mode to really serve each of these distinct corridors that you can see on the map?
And it looks a little crazy still.
They're still yet to be refined, but there's generally a couple of main corridors that start to emerge that connect.
You can see Eagle Mountain and planned development in Eagle Mountain in the future as well as, you know, to Front Runner up here to Lehigh
and into the point of the mountain and getting access into the regional network.
So that is kind of where we're headed as we start to refine.
I wanted to just talk a little bit more about land use and the kind of land use relationship to the transit corridors that we're looking at.
I think as I have been involved in the study now for six months with with the partners, there's things that cities and municipalities can control in transit development, which is really cool.
Your sphere of influence is really directly land use and where you put new development, the kind of development that you bring around a transit station.
You can you can aim your population and jobs to be clustered near transit to give good access to that transit for for young people who want to live and not have a car.
That's a thing we're seeing more and more that young people just don't like to drive.
And so having a place where they can live and work easily connected by transit.
It's exciting.
You all as communities and cities can control transit oriented development policy.
So that's in zoning and where you want that development to be in your city and the station access.
So sidewalks, bypass, good connections to transit.
Those are all things that as a city you can pull and you can really direct ones.
And clearly things that the regional partners might might have more of a say on are the types and frequency.
If there's good land use policy around stations, it's having a good frequent service that makes it all comes together really well in a really smart way.
And ultimately, we're hoping we get competitive with travel time in a car.
And it's better.
I can ride the transit vehicle and get on Wi-Fi or get on my phone and work or read a book or sleep versus sitting on I-15 in traffic.
And I've had to do that and I terribly don't like doing that.
So we want to be more competitive with cars.
And as the region grows and congestion grows, that's becoming more and more important, I think, as we look at this.
So when we think about sort of what what cities can influence and what your sphere of control is, we really have been talking a lot of partnership about land uses around stations and what that means.
Right. So I know these three cities that are part of our study area, Lehigh, Saratoga Springs and Eagle Mountain are very fast growing communities.
I think some of the fastest in the whole valley.
And what we really want to figure out is where do we put transit as you grow over time to become bigger cities, if you will.
Where does transit go that will really help your residents and people who are coming into your city to go to work?
Do it in a way that makes sense and is easy for them from transit.
And so we've been talking a little bit about the different kinds of development that sort of aligns with different mode types.
And it's a little different depending on how intense development is, depending on how this is all about people, how many people live near a transit station that would warrant, say, a light rail train versus a bus rapid transit versus a local bus.
So that's something that we've been working through and thinking about.
And really, we're going to be digging into that more in November with the cities and the partnership to think about, you know, the investment type and how much do you spend on transit?
And what is the community that's getting served by that mode, if that makes sense?
And we're not talking about, again, be very clear, this is not downtown Salt Lake at all.
This is more about sort of residential housing types or mixed use development.
Maybe there's ground floor retail and restaurants or a coffee shop and there's a couple of stories of residential on top.
We're not, you know, for bus rapid transit in particular, we're talking about fairly modest development, but that's clustered around transit stations and attracts people into the system.
Good walking paths, good access on the bikeways and the connection into maybe the more suburban areas.
And same thing for light rail.
This is maybe a little more intense.
There are some pictures of downtown Salt Lake on here, but it's really about, again, people being able to get to transit and justify spending a lot of money on transit to help our community move about the region and do what they need to do in their life.
And we really wanted to also say there's some things that are not going to be supportive of transit.
And maybe those are land uses that exist now.
And the cities can be thinking about, OK, as those properties turn over in the next however many years, you know, car washes, gas stations.
Those are not usually helpful to be next to the transit line.
So we can think about, again, city, you all have such a great amount of influence and a great opportunity to grow your communities around transit in an awesome way.
And we want to sort of help you think about how to do that over time.
So these are these are longer term investment strategies.
This is all not going to happen necessarily overnight, although I'm always impressed with how fast we get things done in the Salt Lake Valley and in the region.
And I know, you know, we'll come up with a good plan to get to where we want to go and then be able to grow our communities around transit in the future.
So in terms of next steps, just real quick. So we are really focusing on why and what.
So we know what quarters we think we want and what's the transit mode that goes with it.
Is it bus rapid transit? Bus rapid transit is kind of like light rail light.
It is a bus, but it usually has dedicated stations. It sometimes runs in its own guideway, like a dedicated corridor.
It's got its own fair media. It's got a branded vehicle.
There's a you might all be familiar with the EVX service there in Ogden and Orem.
And and there's ways to make that even more like sophisticated.
So it kind of looks like a light rail, but it's actually a bus.
And then there's light rail, which is the track system there locally.
Or is it more appropriate to start building maybe the faster buses and a local bus service to help complement some of the higher investment modes?
There's different costs for those those investment types.
Light rail is very expensive bus rapid transit, a little more moderate.
And certainly there's a lower cost to investing in an initial sort of fixed route bus service.
So we want to start playing with, OK, where where are the corridors?
What's the mode that makes sense as the people are growing in the land use around those quarters is growing.
And then as we go into the new year, we'll be starting to look at how do we create a vision and a blueprint and roadmap to execute and make it happen and grow transit and grow grow into the services we all desire.
I will be quiet now. That was a lot. And I appreciate I threw a lot of information at you.
I'm happy to go back and unpack this a little bit or answer any questions.
Lauren, I can certainly walk you through any questions you have or concerns.
And we've been very clear throughout the process, you know, this is a partnership.
And if there's not feeling good or there's not good vibes or we're just a little bit nervous, we really want to understand that.
So we can help read, read, redirect the process to bring everyone along and get to a good space that we all feel really comfortable with.
So we'll probably hear you a lot tonight. And if there's anything we can do to create a process that makes you feel like you're more engaged or you're more comfortable in the process, we want to know that.
So we can we can do a good job and get to get to a plan that everybody can feel good about and can actually.
I just let them finish.
I think like I said, just let them finish.
We can do that.
Does anybody have any questions for them?
In the study, did you also look at corridor widths that need to be preserved to accommodate not just the bus rapid transit, but future light rail?
Yes, yes and no.
We've certainly received from a lot of the city's input on where there has already been corridor preservation happening.
So we have that as a foundational piece.
We are just starting to get into a little bit more granularity on the quarters that have been identified.
I'll just map up so you can see it.
So on these map, these lines that we've drawn, we are starting to talk to city staff about what are we going to face in terms of quarter width?
What's possible? What's not?
So that's starting to happen in the conversation.
So we understand as these go forward, some challenges, constraints or other things.
So we've got a little initial feedback, but we haven't yet gotten into the details.
So we will be doing that coming up in the next couple of weeks.
The most expensive part of transit is the land.
So it's important that we are coordinating with all the cities to make sure that we're preserving land in the same corridors and the same alignments, because it's a waste of taxpayer money and state money if we're buying corridors where we'll never be having any of this.
So the sooner we can get those identified and how much we need to preserve, the better, because the last thing we need to do is build a bunch more houses and businesses that are going to have to get torn down as well.
So the sooner we can get that, the better.
Yeah. Yes. Agreed.
Well, let me start with the statement.
I am thrilled that the central corridor is under construction.
So I didn't know, but I'm excited to find that out.
Anyway, the question is, is I don't know if there's been any discussion and I participate in as many of these meetings as I can on this fresh look.
But I don't know if there's been any discussion yet, or if there's going to be on whether or not some of these routes that are being lived that are going to have your own series.
Meaning, are you looking and studying what has to happen first before we can build these other routes, or are you just looking about building some of these routes intermittently where there might be some pressure and then eventually take care of the activity?
Is that discussion going on?
It's starting to happen.
We've been really focused at first on the identification of the corridors, but what we started to touch on in September is the idea, and this is very common across the country.
I see it in other projects that I've worked on of kind of building a corridor around maybe a fast bus, ridership grows, we invest in bus rapid transit, ridership grows some more, and ultimately we're going to end up with light rail over time.
So kind of this idea of phasing over time, as ridership and the community grows with the transit, but doing that in a way that you're making some initial investments to preserve the corridor to the earlier point.
So we started talking about that as a concept in the September meeting, and I expect we're going to get more into that.
In particular, in some of the Eagle Mountain alignments we've been really ruminating on, we think there's a really amazing opportunity here to align general plan, zoning and land use in these transit quarters together, and really take them all forward at the same time.
So we can be thinking about how do you phase things in over time and what do you need to what do you need to do first second and third that will all be part of the blueprint vision that we come to at the end of what steps are going to be needed over what timeframe to really make these happen.
And just really quickly to the first thing that you brought up about the central corridor bus rapid transit I don't know that it is under construction, so we have under construct that the gray line is for things under construction or with a locally preferred alternative.
So there's a certain amount of study that has gone into a corridor and our friends at Meg just said that that would be a good one to identify that that that is being looked into.
So just wanted to clarify that.
Oh, I have a question last last month in a stat meeting with city staff.
The map showed the highest ranking corridor for for as pioneer crossing.
I don't see that on this map anymore, can you can you speak to that.
Sure, yeah, of course.
You know, to come as that being like medium possibility.
Right.
Higher than anything else.
Yeah.
Well, not only is pine across the city, but Pony Express has a gap through the ranches.
To understand why thousands of cars coming through Saratoga Springs on Pony Express, I would love to see some of those people on buses, but this is showing the high capacity route, bypassing the ranches completely.
It would go through the ranches.
But it doesn't.
It's a little UT existing local bus.
They don't have the orange going through the ranches.
They're going down ranches parkway.
It's a blue one.
That's where that yellow goes through.
I don't know why it's not going to Mountain View corridor through Saratoga Springs.
That doesn't make sense.
Because on the old one, it shows that going down Mountain View.
Yeah, it makes more sense for it to go down there.
This is so confusing and Pioneer Crossing is the busiest road.
We got $1.3 billion to fix Pioneer Crossing and there's not even no kind of plan for bus rapid transit or any like long-term Pioneer Crossing.
Nice.
So one of the so part of the process since early September, we had shared some based on what we got at the July meeting, which was a lot of ideas, right?
We did a little bit of work on performance.
I mentioned that earlier performance measures, and that really is looking at future land use, looking at potential rider markets, looking at a myriad of things that would, again, from a context of traditional sort of performance for transit, how do these start to look in terms of viability?
And viability meaning transit supportive or not, and we might have a little bit of a work to do.
When we got together with the larger partnership meeting thereafter, and we re-workshop some of the lines, this is what kind of came out of that after some discussion.
And I think it's still subject to continued refinement in terms of, do we have the right line work?
And I will say there was a whole lot of debate in that meeting about this, I hope you can see what I'm pointing to, this sort of lakefront, if you will, versus coming up here on Pioneer.
So we really, really debated that with the Utah County representatives from the cities, and I think it's still going to be subject to some further conversation about, is this the right set of combinations of roads?
What I think we heard very clearly is, and this doesn't quite show it, this little yellow should probably get to the American Fork Frontrunner Station.
But we're trying to connect, excuse me, I think this is when you're, we're trying to get to Frontrunner, right?
We're trying to get these, this community connected to the regional network.
And we debated which roadway is the right roadway.
So I think that's something we can continue to talk through.
And then the Mountain View Corridor was, you know, your friends in Salt Lake County really felt like we have I-15 at Frontrunner, and we have a huge gap between, before we have any other north-south transit corridor.
Could Mountain View Corridor be one that we would put some kind of bus rapid transit, or maybe even light rail someday on it?
And if we did that, where in Utah County could it interline?
And what we see is it could come here and create a really nice intermodal hub to connect to these lines that are, that are going into Eagle Mountain, that are going across to connect to Frontrunner.
So this, this is just a concept and very big fat lines on the map of representing the idea that there's some interest in getting Mountain View as a north-south connector into Saratoga Springs to help connect these other kind of transit corridors.
So they probably become in their own right, discrete transit lines that would get developed in the right way for those community contexts, if that makes any sense.
So more to come on this, these are not final by any means, we're still kind of ruminating through what's the right combination of things.
And, and so I appreciate the comment that maybe we don't have this line quite right.
I think that's what I'm hearing is that maybe is, is it a lakefront or is it a pioneer crossing?
So we can keep, we can keep looking at that.
It's both with 200,000 people.
Between Eagle Mountain and Saratoga Springs alone, it's 200,000 people.
Yep.
And so it makes sense to have Pony, Pony.
To be honest, the 2100 one doesn't make sense.
That's a freeway.
It makes more sense to have Pioneer crossing, you know, Pony Express, and then maybe something of, you know, you've got the one for, um, Porter Rockwell.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a good comment.
We'll, we'll go back and talk that out.
I know we want to take a bus when people are going 80 miles an hour past the moment in the car.
Yeah.
When someone did, I was just saying, sorry, it's quiet.
People don't want to take the bus when they're sitting on the bus on a freeway and people are going past them 80 miles an hour in a car.
Yeah.
Where if you're on Pioneer crossing and you're going on a bus and you're passing everyone who's in gridlock traffic, you're like, oh yeah, I'm doing right.
I'm, this is the way.
Right.
So you've got all this high traffic on freeways, which has been proven like the buses on I-15 get passed.
And that's why you don't see as many because no one wants to ride the bus that gets passed.
Yes.
You have to beat the traffic time.
That's true.
Yeah.
Right.
Fast, frequent, easy, safe.
But I'm going to get to a hub somewhere.
Yeah.
2100 technically takes you, but really 2300 west in Lehigh.
Something that takes you off of Pony Express and other making that bigger and having that be the bus rapid transit comes out of Eagle Mountain,
crosses Redwood Road, let's get off of Redwood Road, and then take 2300 right up to the Lehigh station station.
So, I don't know, just, yeah.
So, now, we're going to shut down the cities for a few minutes.
All right, if there's nothing else, I think you guys want to grab Luzo.
And the phone is in a frequent, in fact, I think there's a few other things too.
So, they're going to shut down the point of the street, which is the problem, and it's not difficult.
So, they're going to shut down the point of the street, which is the problem.
So, they're going to shut down the point of the street.
They're going to shut down the point of the street.
So, they're not going to shut down the point of the street.
So, they're going to shut down the point of the street.
Just to clarify, were all the questions done?
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you so much for having us.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
Thanks.
You know, I've got this old PowerPoint that we had with the same engineers.
Oh, yeah.
This is the old PowerPoint we had last year.
We had this new PowerPoint.
It shows that.
I don't know if you like that.
Is it one of the people that I thought?
Yeah.
I have to explain.
No.
I don't know.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's fine.
Yeah.
There's everyone driving.
It's okay.
Did anyone here tonight ride the coaster?
Did you ride your bike?
What?
I think it was a little bit.
It was a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know I also can bother you.
They may go break through schools.
There's much schools from the '70s,
they've never been built in our country.
Most years, anything is not acceptable.
It's not intended.
Yeah, I mean, you have one problem from people.
They're not using people.
And it's just a housing thing.
You realize you stayed every day.
You know, you're not going to buy a house.
Although 20 minutes is a little bit.
You think about the numbers of the hill,
you see your friends,
some of the five minutes in the house.
You know, the house is usually 100 feet per foot.
You're paying 350 a square foot,
and it's kind of 90s.
That's the best thing in the 1970s.
You're paying $600,000.
You're paying your square foot of the house.
And it has your upgrades to a good point.
Yeah.
And it's really great.
It's all right.
Yeah.
So when we've landed in here.
I mean, we still miss a lot of things about it.
I mean, it's a good reason.
We're going to Safeway.
That's good.
Yeah.
It's a good reason.
We're going to Safeway.
That's good.
And Gary's actually a team kind of low-means.
Yeah.
Fears.
That wasn't even like a fancy.
Oh, okay.
What is this?
I can't afford it.
It's not like we love pork.
What's it doing?
Well, I don't know why.
Bacon and sausage.
Oh, man.
Can't do it.
I love it.
Yeah.
And after a couple months.
I don't know why.
Bacon and sausage.
Oh, man.
Can't do it.
I love it.
Yeah.
And after a couple months.
I still hear it there.
I still hear it.
I offer it.
what would be a lot of people.
I still hear it.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Thanks.